Oh
in a recent interview with Variety
magazine actor Idris Elba stated that
James Bond should be played by a woman
emphasizing that it would be something
different
whilst I respect the actors work and
even championed him to be Daniel Craig's
replacement I massively disagree with
the statement while some may think this
is sexist and just as bad as when Doctor
Who fans cried out that the female
replacement was the worst idea ever I
love that take on the character and it
seemed wholly refreshing for the
archetype this instead is a look at the
lack of creativity in Hollywood that is
abundant at the moment and how rather
than develop something different they
would rather just subvert the
established in all honesty I'm sick of
the mentality of just make the character
this demographic instead it is lazy and
shows a lack of understanding towards
values why not just make the female
equivalent of bond and also leave James
Bond as a male not every character has
to have a gender swap if a character
isn't for you either let them be and die
off or invent a new one that focuses on
the issues that you want to raise case
in point
Black Panther sees its release next
month and many fans including myself are
very hyped for what the film will do in
theaters and the Hollywood
infrastructure itself never before have
we had a black superhero lead that
seemed to be in the limelight in such a
positive way this could truly be
revolutionary and changed the thinking
of the way studios and the world
approached the comic book genre now
imagine how lessened that effect would
be if they'd already made the movies
where Black Panther had been played by a
white actor in just swapping out the
race you also lessen the meaning this
was made evident by the race swap of
Mary Jane in spider-man homecoming sure
it was a good choice and something
different but did it really enforce the
values of equality and give the black
community something that they could
rally behind personally I don't think it
was anywhere near as creative as the new
black love-interest Liz this original
character was far more interesting and
massively overshadowed Mary Jane Tudor
originality she ended up being more
empowering and her interracial lineage
much more relatable adresses statement
doesn't really seem to do anything other
than
pounded towards people another example
is Wonder Woman Wonder Woman has always
been a woman and therefore at a call she
is always a tentpole for women's rights
and strong female leads when the movie
was released there was an Oscar talk
this was all centered around an original
female character now Wonder Woman is
opening the door for other female
superhero characters we've seen
confirmation of a black widow
and Batgirl film and this all seems like
a positive step forward again
imagine if Wonder Woman used to be a man
I'm not exactly sure how that works but
just imagine if all that happened and
Wonder Woman man was suddenly swapped
out to a different genre then would the
movement be as progressive as it was I
doubt it and that is why we should
always look for new characters to be at
the forefront of new ideas in relying on
the past we constantly remain there also
I don't really think any audience member
could keep a straight face if they ever
heard the names bond Jane bond in a
movie so that's my thoughts on the Idris
Elba female James Bond debacle do you
agree is it time we had a female bond
why is this better than just creating a
new character comment below and let me
know because I'd love to hear your
thoughts thanks for checking out the
video and if you'd like to see more
points of views on films comics and
games make sure you subscribe to my
channel even though I'm clearly a
massive sexist take care peace
you
[Music]